it's a pleasure to be here today and I
want to spend the next few minutes with
you talking a little bit about about
essentially a couple of topics the first
question I want to ask you to all of you
and I promise I'll repeat whatever i'll
c is for the podcast so who of you wants
to start a company one day okay that's
about seventy percent and who of you is
interested in mobile that's about what
forty percent the rest of you don't have
a cell phone got it all right so who of
you has have already started a company
before wow that's cool that's about five
percent i would guess and how many of
you have basically run out of funding
okay that's about the same group got it
so with that I would like to ask you the
last question which is who wants to know
how to potentially not run out of
funding okay that's about eighty percent
so I think we're in the right room let's
get started so I would like to take you
on a journey today and I'd like you to
sort of be as present as you can and
sort of imagine yourself being on that
journey imagine you are a monk in Bhutan
okay imagine that picture it who I'm not
going to ask who has already been a monk
in Bhutan so imagine you are at 10,000
feet altitude and you will wear a red
robe and you are in one of those
countries that basically has gotten the
internet in 2004 on the same day that
television was switched on and on the
same day that mobile phones get switched
on and on the same day the internet got
switched on and all of this because of
the the Kings anniversary of his
intonation now it is 2008 it is four
years later
how many percent of the boot on
population in the Himalayan mountains
has the internet for years later six
percent how many percent of the boot on
population has a mobile phone sixty
percent and how many percent of the
monks have a cell phone practically
everyone because if you are at 10,000
feet altitude you need a connection to
call your parents so therefore I was
actually there in 2008 I walked around
and I saw a few monks actually huddled
on the ground like this and they were
all looking at something and I was
wondering what are they doing there what
is right there are they playing a game
and in the middle was a cell phone a
smart phone and they were playing
ringtones and being really entertained
by them and I thought to myself if there
is a business in terms of creating
entertainment for monks at 10,000 feet
altitude in Bhutan then mobile and
shopping might be a really good
combination I was actually traveling the
world just for fun I had left CBS mobile
in Los Angeles I had already done two
mobile companies and I was ready for a
big break and so I was traveling the
world with my then girlfriend and now
wife and we were going to 11 countries
in two months we went to New Zealand and
Bhutan and Nepal and India and South
Africa and the Amazon jungle and we
really just wanted to take a trip and it
turned into a venture about
understanding how people use mobile
phones and how they change their lives
in total I took one and a half thousand
photos of people using their smartphones
and you can see a few of those here and
that they're just going to run through
while I'm talking but really the thing
that I took away was a deep inspiration
I was trying to find a place in the
world where people didn't have phones
and so I traveled further and further
away all the way into the Amazon jungle
it didn't work in the Himalayan
mountains didn't work in South Africa
where in fact you know the the people
that were actually they were actually
doing safaris were informing each other
where they found the Rhinos based on
text messaging so that didn't work and
so then I went to the Amazon jungle and
I thought here there must be a place
where there is no cell phone anymore so
two went to Manaus when outside of
Manaus took a trip down the Amazon River
and then outside of the outside of the
of the city far away there was a village
with 25 people living there they had one
washing machine connected to one main
power line for the village think of it
as a strip just a strip which is a power
line and a washing machine attached and
they had 23 cell phones so that didn't
work either and after that didn't work I
sort of gave up and went back to the US
and I thought I might as well be part of
this again and so I was really inspired
and I thought wow this is actually
what's so unique about this is that
mobile phones are not just there for
doing all kinds of entertainment and
business and whatever we all do here in
this room except all of you who don't
have a cell phone but it's actually the
only computer that most people in the
world have it's the only one they do
their finances on it they listen to
their ringtones for entertainment they
call each other they look at the news
there is no other computer and so I took
it back to the developed world and I
thought okay this is really interesting
what are we going to do with this so I
want to take you a little bit on a on
that journey of starting a company in
mobile and what you learned from it
because there seemed to be a lot of
people who want
start a company one day a few of you
were interested in mobile and then there
were a few people who wanted to know how
not to run out of funding now I know how
to run out of funding so therefore i can
tell you how to get there and then i can
tell you what happened after that so the
time i ran out of funding was in my
first startup in 1999 i started a mobile
company and cell phones had green
screens at the time text messaging was a
geeky thing even in europe which means
something I live I grew up in Germany
but I called my mobile virus in Tokyo i
lived in japan in in 1994 and at the
time they had these very large clunky
machines called mobile telephones they
were mobile in the sense that you could
carry them they had a handle and a
receiver you could pick up and I was
fascinated by that thought I thought
this is actually going to change the
entire world how people communicate how
they live everything is going to change
and I remember pressing my nose again
sort of like the the shopping window of
a store that carried a mobile phone it
was the first one that was in two parts
it was one part it was this big and had
a big antenna and I thought wow this is
like unbelievable it costs like ten
thousand dollars and I thought maybe one
day in 20 years I have that money to buy
that and so five years later I started a
mobile company that this was at a time
in 99 when most companies were setting
out websites and I thought the next big
thing is mobile and I was pretty insane
so don't do that so we set up a mobile
company and it became it started as a
mobile auction company turned out to be
the completely wrong business model and
in two thousand in early 2000 for some
of you were already born at that time
the stock market was crashing the bubble
burst we
have no business model and we were
running out of money my two other
co-founders job we came to find fresh
money my job was to became to find a
business model and I don't know who was
worse off so the summer was spent trying
to find a new business model and trying
to find fresh money and essentially what
happened then was that our investors
would they were kind enough to give us a
bridge loan basically that means we're
handing you some debt and if you pay it
back on time fine if not then the whole
company falls to us essentially it's
game over and I remember very well with
that what the date was it was September
16 2000 that was the last possible day
for repayment of the loan and we
actually managed to find new money on
September 17th of that day of that year
and our investors were kind enough to
backdate it by one day so that was how
we did Howie that was how we did not run
out of money and then we transformed the
whole company into a mobile advertising
company and the idea there was that you
could turn a mobile phone into an
interactive device and you would find a
code on the back of a coca-cola bottle
you would text it in and he would get a
piece of entertainment back to your
mobile phone at the time logos were
really hot that was a 24 x 36 pixel
black-and-white LCD display and it was
really cool to create something that is
unique and customized on your phone and
then color came into game into play and
that was just unbelievable and then of
course there was text messaging and
voice and what do you do with that stuff
not a lot right so we created a new idea
which was a mobile greeting card and the
way it would work you would text in your
first name and your friend cell phone
number to a shortcode and that message
then would trigger a phone call to your
friend out of a server and it would be a
normal phone call you would pick up and
there would be an alien on the phone
hello this greeting was sent to you from
outer space who sent it to you will find
out in a second by text message goodbye
and then you would look at your phone
and it would be a text message would say
this message from outer space was sent
to you by Robert if you want to greet
him back or greet someone else just text
in your first name and your friends
phone number and a viral chain kicked
off turns out this was sponsored by
coca-cola and believe it or not the
average times people send that on was
nine and a half per person and every
time they paid twenty cents for a piece
of advertising to send it to their
friends and what does that teach you
besides insanity basically what it says
is that mobile phones are a very
different medium they have very
different it has very different rules
than other platforms and understanding
those rules is very critical if you're
interested in mobile so for several
years I I went along and try to
understand what really happened on
mobile phones and why are they different
and how are they different one of the
things that I found was that mobile
phones are really about intersecting
entertainment personalization and
peer-to-peer those three things together
entertainment it should be entertaining
if an alien call to you if not there's a
different problem and it should be very
personalized if your friend sends it to
you and it's peer-to-peer because it
comes from your friend and not from
yourself so it's for you from your
friend an alien from space and the
intersection of those three things are
really interesting and then there's a
fourth circle if you think about the
three circles right entertainment
personalization peer-to-peer there's a
fourth circle which is not which was not
available in 2003 and that's context and
that is where are you what time of day
is it and so on location technology was
not available it only makes it better
though the principle is the same now
it's all color displays and LTE and
whatever all that is not changing the
fundamental principle of it so with that
I thought ahead sort of cracked it what
mobile is about and I went on and I went
to see
to Los Angeles and I build up the mobil
group and dill of stuff there that was
really fun like CSI games a game that
would call you while you're not playing
it because the crime has just happened
if you're not showing up in the next
five minutes to play the game you about
aging you lose points so those things
are all interesting and fun but I don't
think I really had crap I don't think I
had cracked yet what mobile just truly
about it took me another step further
and I think it took me that trip to
understand what it really meant what I
finally came about was this idea that
people always answer like when you ask a
preneurcast heard that argument before
you can now do this or that anywhere and
anytime and that's why it's great okay
so if somebody says you can now do this
or that also anywhere in any time that
essentially means you could already do
it before correct by definition that is
not a new idea you basically took
something we already know and you
transferred it to a new medium that
can't be it if this is a new medium it
has to have its own ideas so when I went
to KP and I and I was part of this I fun
there were 5,000 business plans that
have been submitted in six months and I
went through a lot of these business
plans and I was looking for the next
cool thing that I could do and I was
really motivated I wanted to find
something and and I put a very important
first filter on on every plan i looked
at which was does this idea work nicely
without a cell phone and if the answer
was yes i would pass does that make
sense if this works
I sleeve without a cell phone it is by
definition not mobile therefore it needs
to not be done what is mobile video
without mobile anybody what it's called
YouTube and what is mobile social
networking without mobile facebook in
other words if you believe these
companies are smart I wouldn't bet
against that they should own this space
there's absolutely no reason they
shouldn't and we don't need another
mobile social networking company so what
doesn't make sense without a cell phone
that's the question what's simply
impossible and that led me to the inside
which I still believe in to this day
what is truly uniquely mobile the answer
to that question that i gave myself is
that this phone is the only interactive
medium that you carry with you in a
non-interactive physical environment let
me say that again smartphones are the
only interactive medium that you carry
with you in a non-interactive physical
environment so for example this table is
completely offline here right it's an
offline things it's wood and until I put
this on top of it and now there is some
sort of digital layer on it some
interactive layer so in other words the
touchable physical world becomes an
interactive place and that is
fascinating because the desktop makes
about point zero zero zero zero zero one
percent of the world and interactive
place namely your desk and this makes
about seventy percent of the landmasses
an interactive place that's really
interesting so if you
leave in that intersection between
mobile and the physical world then the
next question becomes where is the money
unless you just want to build a feature
and there is a big difference between a
feature a product and a company a lot of
entrepreneurs wanted ones who want to
build features or products that's
totally fine I didn't want to do that I
wanted to build a company a company
needs to have revenue streams it should
otherwise a little bit of a problem so
therefore the question needs to be where
is the money on the intersection with
mobile in the physical world and I think
the answer to that is actually quite
simple it's called shopping that's where
people spend their money in the physical
world it's called shopping it's not
called social networking it's not called
mobile video it's called shopping so if
you believe that the next question needs
to be okay so where what is the number
one problem of every retailer in the
world if they all had to agree and I the
answer I gave was they all need to get
people people through the door called
foot traffic because foot traffic is so
important conversion rates are very good
in the physical world they're very good
up to eighty ninety percent in the
physical world when you walk into a
store and about point five to three
percent online so if you can get them
through the door you send a very good
chance of making a sale and it's a 10x
larger market than online so I'm going
to stop here because I don't want to
pitch you shopkick I want to actually go
to the next step I want to explain how
you then go and solve problems as an
entrepreneur I can take that as an
example but not for the sake of pitching
the company so what is the problem of an
entrepreneur the number one problem what
is what is always the problem and you
start a company money actually that it
comes later what's the what is it a good
idea right so an idea right an idea is
important and money is also important
and he is actually great so if you had
an idea you could get money may be right
maybe
and if you have money you could get
staff if you could get staff you could
build a site could build an app you
could start a company in my case this
was it worked like this the idea that I
came out with fur shop cake was if foot
traffic is the number one problem of one
of the largest industries in the world
retail three trillion dollars in the US
alone trillion up billion then how come
no one ever rewards anybody for visiting
a store why only for purchase is why not
for visits why not just for being there
for walking in if that's the number one
problem and the answer to that question
was because nobody has a clue that
you're there until when until you buy
something with your credit card right in
other words until you leave so you walk
up to the register you swipe your credit
card they look at you say hi Robert how
are you today and they look back and
they say I'm doing great thank you and
and and then they say bye that's a
little weird isn't it to be greeted when
you leave 100 years ago it would have
been the opposite you walk into a store
you being greeted how is how are your
kids did you like the cereal we sold you
last week nowadays I don't even know
you're there so I had this idea rewards
for walking in just for walking in Oh
idea cool might work big large market
all that great I get to that later then
the next question was okay if you want
to get rewards for walking in then you
sort of need somebody to pay for these
rewards and who should that be the
people who want the foot traffic right
they're called retailers ok so the
retailer should actually pay for this
all right if that's the case then if you
need retailers then what other retailers
going to ask well I I thought ok might
be much better for the consumer if it's
the same points you get everywhere kicks
here kicks they're not different kicks
for and Macy's best buy target and so on
always the same currency that would be
very powerful for consumers because
every retailer the joints makes it
better
there you get to the problem you go to a
retailer and you say this was in the
financial crisis in 08 the world was
coming to an end very soon was just a
matter of time and you basically walk up
to them you say I would love to start a
cross retailer rewards program and you
get rewards just for walking in that
drives foot traffic to you and they said
well that's great who else is in that
alliance well right now it's just you
but that will change okay why don't you
come back if you have others and then
you go to the Sand Hill Road venture
capitalist and you say have this idea
rewards for working in exam not bad
who's going to give out those rewards
well the retailer's great do you have
any yet so if you had a retailer then we
might actually fund you and then you go
to the retailer's they say so do you
have any other retailers yet it's just
you but there are others interested okay
do you have funding yet not yet but if
you then they and they say well is they
then we that's called the chicken and
egg problem of entrepreneurs it's the
number one problem and the number one
job of the cough the entrepreneur is to
break the egg essentially that's the art
of entrepreneurship there's a lot of
science but that's the art how do you
break the egg there's always a chicken
and egg problem because you have nothing
the art of entrepreneurship is to create
something out of hot air and then make
it valuable so the second thing that an
entrepreneur needs to do is to create
assets and reduce risks that's it it's
not that easy but that's it you have to
create assets and reduce risks how do
you do that
by breaking the egg what does that mean
what is an asset an asset can be a large
user base an awesome technology that's
hard to copy that solves a big problem a
viral mechanism that is really hard to
copy and it takes off and it has
increasing returns dynamics or it could
be an enormously strong team of experts
or it could be a partnership contract
that is a make-or-break thing to get the
company going those are assets assets
basically mean valuable things that make
your company valuable if you put it
together and then there's the risk when
you first start starting a company there
you're right here at the risk curve like
one hundred percent risk everything is
uncertain you have no team you have no
idea yet you have no funding you have no
success no user base no technology
nothing you're right here and then your
goal is to bring it down really fast
being the risk curve down for example
come up with an idea well that takes you
20 excuse me twenty percent down not
eighty percent by the way just 20 maybe
ten and then after that you need a team
and then you need funding and then you
need partners and then you need the
first users and then you need the first
million users and they needed first ten
million users and then you need the
first revenue and you do break even and
all you're really doing is they take
down the risk curve and while you're
doing that you're building up assets
does that make sense so that's really
what you're doing as an entrepreneur and
so the question then becomes what are
the models that actually work I would
like to talk a little bit about business
models because that's sort of one of
those things that we don't talk about
enough I believe we all talk about let's
start another Instagram right cool let's
do it Instagram is an awesome what
product awesome product it's a great
product love it is it a company
no could it become a company maybe it's
too late for that it's just going to
choir but it is essentially can still
become a company within Facebook of
course but it was the product and so if
you want to build a company and that's a
decision anybody can make I'm not
passing any judgment in I really am NOT
I really think it's great to build an
awesome feature I think it's great to
build a great product it's also great to
build a great company and you have to
decide as an entrepreneur root which
type you are what do you want to do I
like to go the road of starting
companies because I like to build things
that last and that I like to sort of
like create things that get established
and they can prosper and they can grow
and they people can work there and it
can get larger and it can change
people's lives for a long time so that's
my passion and everybody needs to know
what their passion is so business models
are very important when you build it
want to build a company what is a good
business model so the first thing that
you need is an answer to the question
whose problem does this solve who is the
possible person who actually has a
problem and if you're trying to build
and technology first and then find us a
problem to that solution then you have a
problem what was that yeah so I'm not
going to repeat that one so there is
there a lot of there are a lot of
different companies that get started
around to technology and then you're
sort of fishing for the problem that
this solves and it's very exciting but
that is not a good company idea so in
the in the case i want to just use that
as an example so the rewards for walking
and you remember that rewards for
walking in so how do you know somebody
who has walked in gps can't do it the
accuracy level is two blocks you can
check into a starbucks right from here
and it's two blocks away that doesn't
work so how do you do it we had to come
up with a whole new location technology
and there was no other technology out
there they could solve
problem so we actually had a problem we
called it the threshold problem because
we needed to know that whether somebody
has called has crossed the threshold of
a store it's actually really hard to do
so my first idea was maybe you can look
at degrading satellite signals as you
walk into a structured as a building and
therefore under identify that you've
just walked into a building because the
quality of the satellite signal just
went down well that's really nice but
that data is not available you don't get
that from Apple or or from Android you
don't know that so therefore we had to
come up with a new technology and
basically this is a little box that you
plug into a power outlet and basically
it emits an inaudible audio signal at
twenty-one thousand Hertz above the
range of human hearing and inside the
signal is a unique code embedded that's
different for every store the microphone
of the smartphone can pick it up decode
it and knows exactly which store it's at
it's so accurate that we would know
whether you're in this room or just next
door in the hallway and that's the kind
of accuracy you need if you want to
reward people something that has
monetary value it's not so cool to
reward people for being in the parking
lot or worse next door at a competitor
store so what I'm trying to get at is
not how great shopkick was but actually
it was important to create this without
it was not there was no company so we
had to wreck our brains how we solve
this problem and create a technology
around a consumer problem that we were
trying to solve and now I beacon is
coming into the game and Bluetooth Low
Energy and they those technologies have
lots of problems too they bleed through
walls they're spoof of all and so on but
there are ways to take combined
technologies and make them really hot
and basically take the upsides of
different technologies and avoid the
downsides of them so the problems remain
they keep going the point I wanted to
make is if you want to if you want to
break the egg you have to be very
creative and on the technology side when
you create a business model it's great
to have a core technology but it has to
solve a real problem next point long
short term defense ability versus
long-term defense
ability those are two different defense
abilities both are really important the
short-term defense ability allows you to
enter a market and be safe for a little
bit like this is a great example we
didn't build the company around this
technology we just needed it to get
started other technologies are coming
and that's all great wonderful but we
needed to get an entry to get us going
and be protected for a little bit so we
can start growing lot long term
defensibility something totally
different what's long-term defensibility
increasing returns dynamics viral
mechanics network effects new users
bring new users who bring new users who
bring new users and before you know it
you have 10 million users and they're
all connected to each other and that's a
really good asset now that can also go
downhill quickly if you don't have
consumer value we know we all know of
startups that went up like a rocket
because of viral mechanics and then went
down like a like a rocket that fell from
the sky of course we know that i'm
talking about combining value with viral
mechanics for long-term defensibility so
those two things are really interesting
when you start a company like what's
your short-term defensibility what's the
long-term defensibility and then after
that quite interesting also is the
question should a business model be put
on top and you figure it out as you go
along or not and there are two different
schools of thought my believers that a
native natural business model that's
sort of authentic and automatically
built in is really cool to have where
you don't have to think about okay and
how are we going to monetize this now
where it's automatically part of it and
it makes total sense it has to be part
of it for example when you walk into the
store you earn the points right the
points have to be paid there's a margin
you earn money with it every walk-in is
a revenue them every purchase that you
make at the store is worth something to
the retailer as well and therefore
that's an affiliate fee think of taking
online affiliate fees and bring them to
the offline world which is 10x larger
in terms of revenue so in other words
creating business models that are
automatically natively woven in without
having to think about what are we going
to do next to make some money with it
I'm not saying the second one doesn't
work what I'm saying is I really prefer
the former because it's so beautiful
when it all fits together into one piece
it's like design where things match and
if you can find that it's a real
advantage it's great because then you
don't have to worry about it how are you
going to make money at someday so then
the other thing that that I think is
interesting is is when you start a
company is the team so that's one of the
things that I'm very passionate about if
I could only do one thing I you might
have figured out by now that I'm
passionate about mobile despite that I'm
actually even more passionate about
building awesome teams so if I had to
choose one thing only I would choose
that why because awesome teams are the
secret ingredient of every success it
doesn't matter whether your idea was
great if you don't have an awesome team
to execute on it if you have a mediocre
idea and an awesome team you have a
chance to find a good idea later if you
have an awesome idea with a bad team
you're done and apart from that I'd
simply love growing great teams because
it's so awesome when you see the
dynamics kick in and people are building
things together it's just very rewarding
so what makes an awesome team and I
wanted to share that philosophy with you
I don't know if it will make sense to
everybody but it's what I've lived by
and what has worked for me and so I
wanted to share that I don't never
shared that it outside of outside of my
own company so I think an awesome team
is made up by four things the first one
is individual brilliance
when I say individual brilliance I'm
talking about 10x very good I'm talking
about outliers I'm sure there are a few
of you in the room individual brilliance
is very rare so it means you're just
amazing at what you do and by the way
this is not limited to intellectual
skills and so on I don't know if you've
ever been to a coffee shop where a
barista who made your coffee was just
amazing and they were just so much
better and nicer than anyone you've met
before have you had that experience
before or you flew an airline and a
flight attendant was just unbelievably
great or somebody at a store helped you
and they were just so much better than
anybody else or you had a teacher and
they just stuck out of the mass and they
were just so much better than all the
others do you know that feeling outliers
individual brilliance now here's the
problem if you take individually
brilliant people and you put them in a
road they're likely going to kill each
other and so what do you do to solve
that problem that's where the second one
the second circle comes in first one is
individual brilliance the second one is
a set of shared values that are very
unfledged arian flexible so for example
integrity high aspirations change the
world attitude can do attitude work hard
play hard those are values that all the
people that are these individually
brilliant people need to adhere and
agree to and only if everyone agrees to
change these values then will change
them otherwise we're not and this person
needs to either adapt or leave in other
words not flexible at all so now the
third one the third one is outside of
these individual very unflattering
extreme diversity so in other words you
have people who are very different at my
company right now at shop cake we have
people who come from the fashion world
they worked at Vogue before and you have
hardcore developers who are absolutely
outstanding in their field some of the
best engineers you will have ever met
yourself and you have people in business
development who are unbelievably good at
striking deals right there are very
different people they look different too
as you can imagine one worked at the
vogue the other one did so so in other
words very different but outside of
these value outside of these values they
are completely diverse but inside
they're very aligned and because they're
so aligned on what matters it works and
then the magic kicks in and then the
fourth pun comes into into effect
because now if you don't have the fourth
one then people might just go crazy and
awesome things but they all don't help
the company so you need a mission and a
vision that people believe in and if
they all believe in the same vision it's
like a wind blowing into one direction
and then it gets really powerful and the
combination of awesome individual people
with values and diversity creates in a
super interesting culture because these
people are interesting they're all
different and so the culture becomes
very exciting to work at so you know it
take it goes from whiskey Tuesday's to
wacky wednesdays today's wacky wednesday
we were supposed to dress up like crazy
people today I couldn't do that because
I went to Stanford I'd I tried my best
that's all I got today so there is lots
of different things happening that neat
that that are created I don't create
these things the team creates them and
it happens when you put this mix into a
room one other point I wanted to make
about culture culture i believe is
highly underrated
people like to talk about culture but
the execution of culture is actually
very underrated I think and I wanted to
explain why I think culture is so
important let me give you an example
let's say you started a new company and
you are the newbie and you're sitting at
your little desk and there are people
around you and now you're thinking about
mmm can I get up and get a coffee I just
started here is that gonna be okay mmm
what if I hang out for 15 minutes in the
kitchen is that gonna be okay this is
where culture comes in culture is a
decision framework it's not just some
fuzzy little nice little things values
it is a decision framework in that
moment you make your decision based on
the culture of the place and then you go
to the kitchen you hang out there and
you might have had the best idea of the
day talking to other people hanging out
having your coffee which you would never
have had if you had stayed sitting at
your desk so my point here is with this
very little example this happens all day
long the decisions are constantly being
made so culture is like a wind and it
blows into one direction if you have a
strong culture it blows everyone into
one direction so if everyone moves in
the same direction you are basically
adding up the forces maybe even
multiplying them if you are moving in
two different directions you kill each
others energy that's why culture is very
important it's a wind a force that's
blowing so in essence the key things I
wanted to get across to you today is as
an entrepreneur you have to break the
egg you need to create assets and reduce
risks noble is about the fact that it's
the only interactive medium you carry
with you in a non-interactive physical
environment so you can make the world an
interactive place that previously wasn't
interactive I also wanted to tell you
about teams and dynamics and what makes
one awesome team when you build your own
company one day remember individual
brilliance combined with values not
these don't deflect
still about it flexible about it but
bring diversity and nevertheless and
create a great mission and so I think
one of the things that that's important
in that regard is also when you start a
company with your co-founder the same
principles apply only multiplied and
even more important when in doubt you're
not exactly sure about the other person
do not co-found with the person it's
really important because you're going to
be stuck together so deeply you have to
really like each other and respect each
other and there can't be any doubt if
you have doubts it's probably right not
to do it the same is true for high rig
by the way when in doubt don't hire when
you're in pain and you need really
strong help because you're so
overwhelmed and you have doubt don't
hire take the pain because it's very
important to build this awesome team it
changes everything so therefore no
compromises regardless of how hard it is
we're constantly in pain but we have to
be if we're I would be surprised if I
suddenly get too many people to hire we
talked to many many people and only very
few make it through the process and it's
on purpose we have to be that way
otherwise we're not going to create that
awesome team that makes the difference
in the end so I think I've run out of
time so we can open it up for for QA and
I'd be happy to take any questions you
have hopefully it wasn't too boring go
ahead oh the question was how do you how
did you break the chicken and egg
problem with the retailer's there's a
long story I'm going to try to keep it
really short essentially I went to a lot
of retailers I I rented the smallest
rental car I could buy I could get and
drove through the Midwest from retailer
to retailer in late oh aight and I
knocked on the door and I said hey this
is the future you should really think
about mobile and they say well we just
fired our staff because it's the
financial
Isis so not really sure so then finally
I got one meeting and it was towards the
end of my entrepreneur and residence
ship at Kleiner Perkins and I had
already spent five months there I didn't
have a retailer and there was this call
with best buy at seven thirty in the
morning and we were sitting around the
table and I thought okay this is the
moment when I have to go all in this is
it I had already spent countless months
worrying about this so on the call I
went all in just trying to convince the
other side you can imagine how many
calls they have they don't really care i
was a it was a conference call is the
worst ever people are probably reading
their emails do whatever so you have to
get a cross on the phone and be so
present that the other side really feels
the inspiration that this is something
unique my only goal is to get a meeting
a physical meeting so they invited me so
i went there and when i walked into the
meeting I knew that this was either the
end of the road or the beginning of a
road and so I came in and I try to
explain to them how what a fundamental
shift this is in thinking about loyalty
and about marketing and about how you
run your business because if you do the
financial calculations the foot traffic
piece is by far the most important one
they don't know how to solve it so I had
my phone with me and I literally walked
out of the room I closed the door and I
said I'm now coming back in and here's
my reward just for being present
wouldn't that be amazing and people
thought I was funny and you know cool
and then soda I went on with the
presentation and I had all kinds of
graphs and there were questions lots of
critical questions as you can imagine
everybody's trying to kill the idea was
finished and then there was one sort of
silence and I then I asked a question I
said do you like it or do you love it
and I also knew that only if they would
say love they would do it possibly do it
with like they're not going to do it
it's not sufficient and that was sort of
like quiet and people were a little you
know uncomfortable with that question
and there was one person in the room she
spoke up she had only been there for one
year at best buy and she spoke up and
she said we are very good here at
killing ideas this one we have to make
possible that slipped the entire
conversation then after that meeting I
had to go through 40 meetings with 60
executives and pitch it over and over
again and convince every single one
because with with one person against it
it would have broken and there was one
person who was not for it she was
unfortunately responsible for loyalty
and so I had this weekend where I was
sitting in my living room and is very
intense and I pink my friend to create
some screens and basically explained to
her how how their loyalty from growers
could be really great together because
it's not a competition it's actually an
awesome partnership where you can have
more you can reward people more and have
more contact points so there were a lot
of reasons why it should be working but
of course he hadn't spent the time to
think that through yet so i pinged her
and i said i want to have dinner with
you and she said i have 30 minutes at
the office and I said I want to have
dinner with you and it was Minneapolis
it was January it was 12 degrees and it
has lots of snow so I went there and
I've actually got her to get out of the
office we went to this restaurant and we
had two wine glasses and a napkin and I
drew the whole thing out for her and
said this is how it's going to be and
this
is how you can get 10x more contacts
with your own people than you ever had
before this is why this works and she
looked at me she said this is brilliant
I love it and I took a photo of the two
wine glasses after she had left I knew
that in that moment shop key was founded
and I took that back home and then I had
to do go through many more things to get
a letter of intent which is not even
legally binding then I took that back to
kleiner perkins I said here it is and
they said now we might fund you then I
was brought to another meeting with 12
people in the room at Kleiner Perkins
and I pitched my case with everybody in
the room all the great partners you know
Matt Murphy John doar Randy commissar
Chiwa there were all these great people
and I had to pitch my case and then in
the end they actually pulled the trigger
I thought I had messed it up completely
by the way I thought I walked out and I
missed the last hurdle it worked and
that's how we where we started but with
that you just broke like one egg and
then you go on you say okay so now i
have a retailer actually wasn't even a
deal yet but it was so sort of like okay
we want to do this and then you have
funding now you need the team the team
obviously was liking it that there was
funding that was helpful now you go to
the next thing and you say okay so now
we need technology and then the
technology guys that do you have anybody
know do you know how this works no do
you have a solution for the threshold
problem not really so it basically just
keeps going so my point what I'm trying
to make is it never stops and when you
an entrepreneur one of the things that I
really believe in is that as an
entrepreneur you have to be ready to be
laughed at for a very long time and
people don't take you seriously in there
are so many startups and all of that
right ninety-eight percent of the time
it's very unglamorous to be an
entrepreneur and two percent of the time
it's freaking awesome
and that two percent makes up for
everything else and it's an amazing
experience and the highs are higher and
the lows are lower and they never stop
but you have to sort of ask yourself
whether that's what you want is that who
you are and when you think you are that
then you should really leap and do it
and if you don't think that's you then I
wouldn't do it because it's not
glamorous most of the time and you have
to know why you're doing it and if
people say like ask me the questions
when is your IPO I have no idea if I was
motivated by that I'll be long gone an
IPO is nothing but a way to inject
capital into a company that's it so if
you want to create a significant
institution organization something that
mattered matters in the lot in the world
and to people then it's not about an
exit it's about the beginning and it's
about the journey and it's about growing
it into something meaningful and I'm not
saying that because it sounds good it's
just my belief that's what it's about
and if you are motivated by something
else not so good any other questions yes
go ahead re-entry with James like PayPal
perhaps chicken puck behind you with
their PayPal vegan and check in and all
this type stuff right the question is
how do you create a long-term advantage
or defense ability with large players
like PayPal entering the market with a
beacon and all of them so the answer to
that question is very simple you have to
create a unique service that so many
people love that it stands on its own
very simple and honestly if you take
this example of payments I have a very
strong opinion on that so obviously I
thought about it right I really believe
and I'm not going to talk about paypal
i'm talking about i'm going to talk
about mobile payments and mobile wallets
okay so please disconnect that a little
bit because i think the paypal team is
awesome
I think that mobile wallets will fail
and the reason they will fail is because
they're empty I don't need another
wallet I have a credit card it's pretty
good I swipe it it works I don't need
any network creativity it always works
it's actually quite convenient so do i
need another payment mechanism not
really so essentially what i'm saying is
that the idea of starting with payment
and let's be clear in this room i don't
think anyone this room wants to pay
payment is the one thing at a store you
don't want to do everything else is cool
not payments you don't want to pay
because that's something that is a means
to an end it's a necessity not something
you love so therefore the more payments
can disappear into the background the
better and so the question is then what
does matter to consumers if payments
doesn't matter what matters and what
matters is very simple it's the shopping
experience I go to a store I don't know
all of you guys buy everything online I
bet it but some of you might actually go
to the store to give you a little bit of
a context of the size of the markets
because it's fascinating on offline
shopping three trillion dollars in the
United States online shopping 250
billion 12x larger growth rates of
online commerce including all amazon
revenue twelve percent a year twelve
percent out of the three trillion
dollars 1.2 trillion are influenced by
online activity before you buy offline
you go online check out a product but
then end up buying it at the brick and
mortar store in other words it's five
times larger than all ecommerce combined
including amazon's revenue that market
the 1.2 trillion is growing at nineteen
percent a year in other words the gap is
widening not closing as most people
believe so this is a very interesting
market probably one of the most
interesting markets so the question then
becomes
five years from today why would anybody
want to go to a physical store anymore
and because of online and same-day
delivery and mobile and showrooming on
price comparison all of that the reason
you go to a store is not because you
need anything I really bill don't
believe that you don't go anymore
because you need anything I I don't even
think you will go because you want
something I think you'll go because you
want to feel better because you want to
feel better because you want to go on a
mini vacation and in order for it to
feel that way the shopping experience
needs to change and that is the counter
point to payments the experience needs
to change I need to walk in and love it
I need to love the design of the store
the whole stores design needs to change
like it can't be that I'll walk around
with a little cart and I pick up items
from a shell threw them into a basket
and then I Drive my little basket to the
register and put myself in the queue in
order to be allowed to pay later
something needs to get better than this
so essentially the experience needs to
change there are two factors one is the
design of the store the products in the
store and the other one is the digital
overlay on top of the physical world I
find this fascinating remember this is
the only interactive medium you carry
with you in a non-interactive physical
environment this can be the digital
layer on top of the physical world this
can turn macys into your macy's this can
tell you what your friends have liked
when you walk in it can give you things
that you show you things that you should
check out here but they're interesting
for you and not for you it can basically
be the lens on it and then google
glasses comes in of course we have one
here already that's all the beginning of
of wearable computing and that's just
the beginning watches will be the
earliest one most likely so all of this
is basically putting a digital layer on
top of the physical world and that is a
very interesting way to make the
experience better and payments needs to
be a part of that but it needs to
disappear so the wallet is not
interesting what's interesting is what's
before the wallet does that make sense
and that's what we're building next
question right oh we're good
unfortunately I think we could go on for
a lot water um those are fantastic gems
thank you very much time so everybody
please join me in thanking Syria
you